thank you Bob for asking me and giving
me the privilege and honor of
introducing our speaker in your remarks
one operative word is old I am old
friend of Fraggles but I'm old enough to
have known our token personally while I
was Brainerd and I were graduate
students here at the Economics
Department and in fact I remember still
remember the watching the Kennedy Nixon
debates at the television we didn't have
television at oken's suicune house
anyway let me turn to our speaker again
I was tempted to start with the
conventional sentence our speaker needs
no introduction and then go on for an
hour's spending entry introducing the
speaker I won't do that I will be brief
Rama Rajan Raghu as he is widely known
is the world acclaimed scholar of the
theory empirics and the practice of
domestic and international finance Raghu
is the Eric glacier Distinguished
Service professor of Finance at the boot
School of Business at Chicago he got his
PhD from MIT with a dissertation on
banking and he did his undergraduate
work and got a degree in engineering
bachelor's degree in engineering and a
gold medal from the well-known
Indian Institute of Technology Delhi he
followed it up with another well-known
management institute in India the Indian
Institute of Management
and Abad birthday an mba degree before
going to MIT
raro served as the chief economist of
the International Monetary Fund during
2003 to 2006 and from this position in
ninety two thousand five he warned the
world of the looming financial crisis
two years before the crisis hit the
world he pushed the IMF to shift its
emphasis emphasis of its research from
macro economics and policy towards
financial sector issues of course Raguse
warning apparently fell on the deaf ears
the dominant members of the IMF such as
the US and you traditionally ignore
whatever I am AB says of whatever IMF
advises them under the annual article
consultants consultation what the IMF
under article 4 so even though the
leading agents of the financial crisis
paid no attention and I hope Raghu will
enlighten us as to whether this time he
is now writing even more about the
financial crisis this time they will
hear him better than they did earlier
the Raghu is on the Indian Prime
Minister's Economic Advisory Council and
serves on the board of Controller
General of the United States I was
privileged to join him in visiting India
central bank namely Reserve Bank of
India and writing a report for its
governor assessing the bank's research
output and capacity and suggesting ways
to strengthen the latter Raguse
contributions have been recognized with
many awards including election as
president elect of the America
finance Association fellowship of the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
Fischer black price of the American
Finance Association for a person under
40 Jenson price Pharma DFA price and the
Brattle price price for distinguished
papers in that journal his widely read
book with Louisa galas on saving
capitalism from the capitalists has
raised expectations about he is eagerly
awaited book dude this June entitled
fault lines how hidden fractures still
threaten the world economy his CV is
long and impressive and he has
co-authored with many people a few
probably influenced few of his papers
probably influenced by his quarters
regrettably engage in cross country
regressions but then nobody is perfect
here is Raghu
thank you thank you DN um well it's it's
a great pleasure to be here at Yale
University and I was going around campus
with my daughter this morning she's
she's certainly interested in in
universities and it was a delightful
experience seeing what a wonderful
campus and university you have and the
it is a particular sort of privilege to
be here with with friends such as TN and
Bob Shiller talked about a issue which i
think is is going to be with us
for many years I think the question that
I want to ask is whether the crisis that
hit us is over
and by that I don't mean just the narrow
features of the crisis are we going to
get a second dip I was going to get a
third dip you know what's gonna happen
to commercial real estate what's going
to happen to sovereign defaults I want
to talk about a deeper underpinnings of
this crisis why did we have this crisis
it was it the first of the crises driven
by the underlying forces I'm going to
talk about is it going to be the last
and if we really want to address it what
are the things that we need to do and
I'm going to start by saying that first
I'll talk a little bit about you know is
this phase of the crisis really over but
then I want to move on quickly to
arguing that this was not the first
crisis that was caused by the underlying
forces this was just the latest and
perhaps the most dramatic and and and
devastating and that until we fix the
underlying forces it is quite possible
we have future occurrences of what
happened different forms in different
areas of the world but it is it is
something that we need to we need to
tackle that's where I'm going let me
start first with
with just defining it and and as I said
but it I don't just mean narrowly this
crisis but but in this crisis clearly
there is somewhere to go
commercial real estate defaults are
increasing increasingly the enormous
fiscal deficits that have been created
partly by government intervention partly
by the fact that when output Falls so
dramatically governments do tend to run
large deficits because the so called
automatic stabilizers like unemployment
insurance start operating
so that has quickly turned this crisis
from a private sector problem to a
public sector problem that is the public
sector finances are now deeply in
trouble across the world not just in the
United States of course when you have a
public sector fiscal deficit which is
large public debt which is large you
quite quickly come to political problems
which is how are we going to tax to pay
for the enormous debts that we've built
up who is going to pay these taxes and
are there more obvious culprits that we
can point to while we are trying to deal
with the underlying problems of this
country and typically when you're trying
to look for scapegoats scapegoats
outside the country who don't vote often
are far a former subject to to blame
then domestic scapegoats and so amongst
the consequences of this crisis we
fallout from dealing with the crisis
that we will we should expect to see is
more political conflict about how this
crisis gets spadeful who bears the brunt
of taxation and and and how that evolves
over time you already see it playing out
in the US Congress over the last few
months a second aspect that we should
expect to see is trade that we already
seeing noises made about the Chinese
currency with the u.s. at 10 percent
unemployment
and China growing at 10% at least for
the moment clearly the language is going
to get more heated over the course of
this year I haven't pointed to get
another consequence of crises of deep
crises which is the conversation or the
conflict over trade sometimes spills
over into actual physical conflict that
certainly was how the Great Depression
ended it's not necessary that it end
that way but that is a potential outcome
of deep conflict so to the question of
is it over yet
no the consequences are still bubbling
through the system the immediate crisis
to the financial system is largely over
for the big banks still developing for
the small and medium-sized banks across
the world some parts of the world they
still have to have to recognize the
costs the losses that they made but it's
moved beyond the financial sector now to
the government sector and beyond the
government sector to the political
sector and so there will be consequences
over time but I also want to argue that
it if we refer to it as this narrow
crisis itself it's actually to my mind a
sequence of crises starting with the
emerging market crisis in the 1990s
evolving into the dot-com bust and then
moving into this crisis but the
underlying forces are still unresolved
and I want to come to that next so I
mean if you if you focus on this
particular crisis itself what are the
popular explanations the immediate
explanations is we had a bunch of greedy
bankers who went in over their heads and
we had a bunch of ideological regulators
who basically said let's say fair let's
stay away let's not do anything to
interrupt this process and as a result
the system collapsed now may that's an
easy explanation and it's an explanation
that's politically you know easy to sell
but there are many questions with that
kind of explanation right the first
question of course is is why now
why did it happen at this time rather
than earlier after what bankers have
been greedy since the dawn of time why
did the bankers get excessively greedy
at this point and create the problems
and and of course there's the additional
point that regulators and the whole
system of checks and balances the
politicians who oversee the regulator's
I mean all that to some extent is
endogenous it's it's part of the system
and so you can't suddenly assume that
you know these guys became ideological
while they became a become ideological
at this time what was it that made them
take their hands off the financial
system and say go for it
more generally when we think of a
sophisticated country versus the
standard emerging market we typically
define a sophisticated country a
developed country as one which has lots
of institutional checks and balances
right which has somehow curbed
the natural instinct for corruption for
excess in the system a developing
country is a country which still is
figuring out how to do that an
industrial country has figured that out
so what happened to the checks and
balances in the United States why did
the United States become an emerging
market and suffer a typical emerging
market crisis to my mind that is one of
the important questions we have to
answer second important question we have
to answer is typically when you have
excess excess happens through much of
the economy and typically you know often
it happens especially when you look at
housing in the upper segments of housing
if you look at past US real estate booms
this typically occurs with the rich
segments the rich segment moves up the
most comes down the most this time it
happened with the poorer segments with
subprime while it was so much of the
action centered around subprime housing
the poorest of the housing segments why
did it happen there again that's
something we need to talk about so I
want to split my explanation into two
parts one is a macro political
explanation which talks about how we got
these circumstances both macro and
political which created the conditions
for the finance
sector to run amok and then I want to
move to a financial sector part of it
which says given these political
circumstances given the macro
circumstances why in fact did the
problems emerge in the financial sector
and the way they did so it's a two-part
explanation let me quickly explain what
the first part is give you an overview
go to the second part and then detail
each of these explanations I want to tie
what happened now but also what happened
to the emerging markets and what
happened in the dot-com boom to a lesser
extent to the path of growth countries
followed post-world War two and one of
the things that is extremely important
to understand is the growth paths that
were followed post-world War two were
quite different from the growth paths
that industrial countries that became
rich followed in the 19th century or
even in the earlier early 20th century
19th century growth was relatively slow
growth was steady growth but slow growth
per capita growth rates for example for
these fastest growing emerging markets
of that time the australia's and the
united states of the world were 1.5 to 2
percent per year but they did that year
after year for a long time and therefore
became very rich post-world War two the
kinds of growth parts we had were
extremely fast growth parts I mean the
classic example is Japan which grew at 8
percent per year between around 1950 and
1973 but other countries have come close
to replicating that I'm talking about
per capita income growth other countries
like China have certainly come close and
and these growth paths were not be
balanced or relatively balanced growth
paths that that other countries followed
they were particularly focused on
exports and I'll and and explain why and
initially for countries like Japan and
Germany they focused on exporting for
growth but they also invested tremendous
amounts and importer lot to make those
investments so it was relatively
balanced but as we got into the 60s and
the same
in these countries became relatively
rich investment started falling off but
the export sector was still exporting a
lot so these countries as you move into
the 1980s start pumping out big
surpluses now when you have two of the
biggest economies in the world pumping
out big surpluses somebody actually has
to absorb them and in the 80s and the
90s it was the emerging markets of the
world and let me focus on on on East
Asia but but certainly there were
countries in Latin America India which
absorbed these surpluses in East Asia in
the 1990s the surpluses were in part
absorbed by increasing the level of
investment so investment for example in
Malaysia Korea and Thailand went from
about 25 percent of GDP to about 42
percent of GDP enormous increase over
the span of that decade before 1997 in
investment financed by borrowing from
abroad and clearly when there are
surplus is generated in some part of the
world the financing is available for
countries that want to absorb those
surpluses and run deficits however that
foreign financing proved unsustainable
and I'll talk about why that proved
unsustainable
unlike the financing of Japan and
Germany when they grew there was a big
difference because this was private
financing rather than government
financing a lot of the financing for
Germany and Japan Germany for example in
the early stages with marshal plan
lending and so on now it was private
finance especially financial markets and
foreign banks and that proved
unsustainable you had a boom in busts in
the 1990s emerging market after emerging
market went down and a lot of these
countries decided that borrowing to
finance growth was a bad idea
and many countries started restructuring
government finances restructuring public
finances even the corporation's
restructured investment and they cut
back certainly in East Asia tremendously
on investment they started cutting their
quote to fit the investment cloth or
cutting the investment to fit the
resource cloth and essentially start
moving away from absorbing surpluses
running large deficits to actually
running large surpluses of their own
okay so you had the old surplus country
is the Germany's and Japan Germany
temporarily running deficits in the 90s
because of the integration with East
Germany but again starting to pump out
surpluses in 2000 coupled with the
emerging markets who found that they
couldn't absorb other people's exports
and they started pumping out exports of
their own so large surpluses moving into
the world economy where who who
increases demand to absorb these
surpluses to start buying more than they
produce and there was an interval in
which industrial country corporations
increase the investment that didn't end
well that ended in the dot-com bust and
so we come to 2000-2001 industrial
country corporations are played out
can't increase the investment they have
only invested who's going to take up the
slack to spend to absorb the surpluses
that are being pumped out elsewhere and
at this point a bunch of countries
oblige the United States the UK Spain
these are the countries that start
running large current account deficits
large trade deficits the question is why
these countries step up and I want to
argue there was something peculiar in
these countries at that time
specifically I'm going to focus on the
US there's something particular about
the US which made it willing to actually
expand like the typical emerging market
and I want to focus on that in in what
follows for a little while the
circumstances I will allude to are
largely political and those political
circumstances in many ways created the
underlying broad circumstances for the
crisis now it takes two hands to clap
one hand came from these macro political
forces which caused the u.s. to run
large deficits to draw in a whole lot of
foreign financing the other hand that
participated in the clapping was
obviously the domestic financial sector
which is where I have the second part of
my explanation the kinds of actions that
the public sector took at that time and
I'll come to them in in greater detail
had two effects one it coordinated the
private financial sector into taking
certain actions and I want to focus on
those actions which I think are central
to this crisis and the second aspect of
that is once the private financial
sector was coordinated into taking some
of these actions they understood that if
these admissions had adverse
consequences because so many of them had
been coordinated into taking these
actions the government would come in and
help the private sector out so as a
result the incentive to maintain
precautions against the potential
downside of the actions the private
sector was taking the breath banks were
taking the investment banks were taking
they incentive to stay away from the
downside decreased because of the
potential coordination and the
anticipation and as a result the
probability of the crisis increase and
eventually actually happened and the
point I want to make is the left when
pointing to this crisis says it was all
the bloody-minded
actions of the financial sector these
bankers hunkering hankering after
bonuses went out and did crazy things I
would argue that that was not all there
was to it there was a hand of the
government which played an important
part in creating the structures which
allow the private sector to take the
risk that it did in the areas that it
did and this is where the subprime issue
becomes very important so I want to
argue the private sector took advantage
of government interests in furthering
certain processes at the same time the
problem is not wholly a public sector
problem also the private sector did do
certain things which went overboard so
it's a combination of those two the
government undertaking certain actions
because of the macro political factors
and the private sector taking some out
actions because the government took
those actions those two came together so
you can't blame just one side here
it is collective blame and therefore the
actions you have to take to resolve this
kind of problem have to be collective so
that's where I'm going now let me get to
details and bring this down to ground
level so I think the problem in some
ways lies with the path of growth that
countries followed so what are these two
pictures just pop quiz which which city
are these pictures of one is the city
right after world war two the second is
the city today okay
the one says this is Seoul Korea and you
can see pretty much a third world
economy in the picture on the left and
you see a first world economy the
picture on the right this is in the span
really from about 90 1960 to 1990 30
years three decades half a lifetime or
even one third of a lifetime for many
people that's the transformation never
before in history have countries
transformed so fast and the question is
how did they do it and I will argue they
did it in ways that created certain
benefits in the short run but in the
long run created certain distortions my
sense is many of these countries and
here I'm entering controversial
territory the the exact factors that
lead to economic growth are still a
matter of great debate but one of the
things that these countries did right I
had seem to have got right is there was
a substantial amount of government
intervention which focused on creating
strong firms often by creating a
producer bias giving subsidies to firms
subsidies in terms of lending subsidies
in terms of raw materials and
time.sometimes subsidies in terms of
protecting them so that they got some
profits protecting them from foreign
entry and competition however if you
continue along that path if you
continued protecting your firms where
you ended up was in a rent-seeking
economy of the kind that in
had an economy which grew very slowly
which was stuck in in the Hindu rate of
growth the countries that got it right
did one more thing while they protected
their firms creating sort of
organizations which had the capability
of growing they also pushed them out to
export India had a large domestic
economy not much incentive to push
countries to export countries like Korea
are countries like Taiwan had a very
small domestic economy so on the one
hand they had really no option but to
export but also they had somewhat
authoritarian governments which pushed
them and didn't have to listen to the
magic of the elections and election
funding they pushed them in and got them
to export and so what these countries
had was a an export sector which was
extremely efficient extremely efficient
extremely good extremely strong
extremely comparative right and on the
one hand they had that on the other hand
because producers were hand in glove
with the government and because the
ability to get that competition to work
domestically was quite difficult they
had an inefficient domestic oriented
sector what what economists called
non-traded goods sector was extremely
efficient just as an example we have
competition with that's a scooter right
okay even while they had an extremely
efficient export oriented sector they
had an extremely inefficient domestic
sector and here the ability of the
producers to go hand in glove with the
government and determine regulations
without any foreign competition limited
the extent to which this sector could
become efficient one example is Japan
many of you who mean to Japan notice
that there still is this institution of
the elevator lady what is the elevator
lady supposed to do well she's supposed
to direct you towards the nearest
elevator which is there
now this is something which doesn't
require genius the light is flashing
there's a bell you know which elevators
there you don't need an elevator lady to
tell you where to go but yet that
institution survives this is an example
of the kinds of inefficiencies that
still survive in Japan haircuts
extremely expensive haircuts are the
quintessential non-traded good the good
for which you can't compete across
borders in the US I can't compete on
giving haircuts in Japan because you
need a physical presence there till such
time as we invent machines that can work
cross-border not going to happen for
sometime haircuts are extremely
expensive in Japan now recently a small
firm started up saying we're gonna
reduce the cost of haircuts are we gonna
make cheap haircuts available in Japan
well they started expanding very fast
because there's a huge demand for cheap
haircuts at which point the barber guild
sort of got anxious persuaded their
friends and the government to take
action and so within a few months they
passed a regulation saying in order to
have safe and clean haircuts you first
have to have a shampoo in order to have
shampoos you have to have facilities
which means a big tub a big wash basin
water and the whole lot of paraphernalia
within a few months essentially they
made it impossible for that upstart to
compete because that upstart had to make
an enormous amount of new investments so
as to give the shampoo and the and and
and do the right things according to the
regulation what I'm trying to argue here
is why these countries have extremely
efficient foreign oriented manufacturing
sectors they have extremely inefficient
domestic oriented sectors largely carta
lies without competition one example of
this is if I ask you name for Japanese
manufacturing firms you can read them
off Toyota or Canon Rico
Nissan I mean you can just reel them off
let me ask you to name three Japanese
four
food restaurants around the world change
harder three Japanese hotels around the
world three Japanese banks as soon as
you move away from the domestic from the
foreign oriented sector to the domestic
sector becomes hot much harder to talk
about examples of non-traded goods in
Japan that that work particularly well
why why am I talking about this well I'm
saying that as these countries follow
the export growth path and became rich
and stop needing to import machinery and
investments from other countries this
did two things one it made them
extremely dependent on exports for their
growth if there was a downturn in the
world economy they suffered enormously
if you look at 2008 the countries that
suffered suffered the worst in the world
economy was not the you know we're not
the United States of the UK we're sort
of the epicenter of the crisis was but
countries like Japan like Germany where
which didn't have financial sector
problems will work so export dependent
that their rates of growth plummeted
East Asia also the second is when they
want to pump up the economy they don't
have effective ways of doing us the
world is in trouble they want to pump up
their own economy don't have good ways
of doing it I mean in Japan because of
the close nexus between the government
and the construction sector a lot of
stimulus often is new projects well over
the 15 years or 15 to 20 years that
Japan has been in crisis since the early
1990s much of Japan is now covered in
concrete because every stimulus program
is yet another building project here
they're everywhere but it hasn't lifted
Japan out of its doldrums because much
of that expenditure is very inefficient
and doesn't really produce is not
effective so what do we have I think
Japan is the arch typical example of a
country that focused on export led
growth and now has become extremely
dependent on exporting in order to grow
cannot move away
to a more balanced economy now because
it has a domestic oriented sector which
is highly paid extremely inefficient and
when you get the combination of people
who have high pair but are inefficient
change is extremely difficult because if
you needed to change in order to get
them to be paired according to their
level of inefficiency you would have to
reduce their wages tremendously not
going to happen so long as their
political power so it is stuck in
paralysis and can't move Germany to some
extent is similar but not as bad
partly because Germany has the
discipline of the euro area preventing
it from the kinds of policies that have
have engulfed Japan over the years the
euro area the european community has
helped increase the level of competition
in germany over and above what it would
have been had been and so on
the big worry now for the world is China
is China gonna go along the Japanese
path so that it focuses on exports still
too late till it can pull back it's
still early days for China but that's a
possibility so we get these surpluses
being generated by these countries
because of the way of growth and then we
have these emerging markets which are
starting along that path of export-led
growth but are still importing a lot in
order to make the investments they are
still running large deficits they
running larger deficits in the 1990s I
will put aside right now the India's and
the Brazil's of the world that's those
were more consumption led deficits
these were investment led deficits in
East Asia but a lot of this investment
in Asia was financed with foreign
capital and the foreign capital came in
the traditional way foreign capital
comes in it basically said you need to
finance stuff we will help you finance
it but we want guarantees we want
guarantees that you won't dispossessed
us of our money and often in these
situations the guarantees come in ways
that are extremely difficult for the
economy in this in the case of East a
the banking system was
by the government and so the idea was if
ever the banks refused to repay there
would be a chance that they would go
under the government would come and
support them and that would uphold the
value of the foreign investors who are
invested in these countries right does
that sound familiar you have foreign
investors putting their money into an
entity that entity is supported by the
government
that means the crisis when it actually
happens the taxpayer will come and repay
the foreign entities think about AIG
think about who are a IG adren claims to
it had written claims in many situations
to foreign entities it was being
supported by the government the foreign
entities came out whole think about
Fannie and Freddie Fannie and Freddie
had written a whole lot of debt claims
held by the foreign investors often
foreign governments of foreign quasi
government entities again supported by
the government eventually so point I'm
trying to make is there's something
about foreign lending especially private
foreign lending which often looks for
government backing and in these cases
the government had effectively given
their backing by supporting the banking
system and created problems so that when
the foreign investors took fright
essentially the government had to come
out and bail out the system enormous
crisis engulfed these countries the they
had to go and borrow from the IMF they
had to subject subject themselves to IMF
conditionality IMF conditionality was
extremely harsh essentially a number of
these emerging markets Bailey said never
again never again are we going to borrow
from foreign capital because it's just
too dangerous it comes in and it leaves
abruptly when it leaves we have to make
it whole because we have to make it
whole our country suffers we're not
going to do this again and so many of
them move towards intervening in their
currency keeping it relatively low
making the export sector even more
competitive and building up large
reserve home holdings they reduced the
investment of consumption and
essentially they added to the problem
which was already growing because of the
surpluses from Germany and Japan this
was now augmented by the surpluses
from the emerging markets okay so the
fault line here was the inadequacy of
cross-border for finance and this is a
picture which gives you a sense of how
big this effect was that you see that
Korea and Malaysia were running deficits
which sizable I mean if you look at the
Malaysian deficit touching near 10
percent of GDP in the 1990s 1996 is the
last year it's negative shoots up to a
huge positive surplus Malaysia now is
running a current account surplus of 17
percent of GDP in other words it
produces are effectively 17 percent more
than it consumes or invests and that
stuff is being shipped out in the into
the world economy okay so these
surpluses went looking for entities to
spend I'll pass over the dot-com boom
which was a temporary episode and then
I'll come to the United States in 2001
corporations aren't willing to spend
who's gonna spend who's gonna up their
spending to absorb these goods which are
being pumped out in the global economy
now I'm sort of caricaturing the process
is more complicated than why I'm saying
but fundamentally it boils down to this
guys are producing a lot pushing it out
in the global economy
somebody has to spend and in the United
States the spending came from households
they increased their spending they also
increased the investment in houses so
housing investment went up and spending
by the households went up a lot of this
came from the poorer segments in in in
in in in the US economy
subprime households and so on now this
was facilitated by extremely
accommodative monetary and fiscal
policies and what I want to talk about
is two things one why subprime why
wasn't it the normal housing boom and
bust and second what role did did
monetary policy play and why did it play
that role why was monetary policy so
accommodative then Alan Greenspan
realized what he was doing I want to
talk about these two things so first
subprime what was surprise the answer to
why did we get so much government push
to
subprime housing I would argue that in
the United States over the last 25 30
years we've had growing inequality if
you look at the wages of the 90th
percentile earner they went from about
three times the wages of the 10th
percentile to about 5 times so they've
grown now most of you hear or read the
newspaper stories about guys at the
point zero one percent level the hedge
fund managers in Connecticut how many
thousands of times in average workers
wage they're making that's one part of
the story but I think the more
interesting and and why some part of the
story is how the office manager is now
making so much more than the median
worker then they used to in the past the
question is why is this happening and if
you look at the the studies on this many
of them focus on education that what is
happening is that the u.s. is losing the
race between education and technology
what do I mean by that I mean that
typically technological progress
proceeds a pace and requires people with
higher and higher higher education to
work in the early part of the 20th
century what you needed was no longer
some years of schooling you needed a
high school education to work in the
chemical plants and the factories that
were being built as we move into the 70s
and the 80s high school education is no
longer sufficient you need a college
education undergrad degree and as we're
moving away into the 2010s it's no
longer just an undergrad education you
need a post-secondary degree at this
point so the demands for education are
increasing what the US has been unable
to do is keep up with the supply and in
many situations not because we don't
have good universities here it's because
the quality of education imparted at
this school level has been falling
behind okay so for example high school
graduation rates haven't increased since
the 1970s which is in alarming fact and
second if you look at college completion
rates they're not different for males
born in the 1940s from
the graduation completion rates for
males born in the 1970s even while the
demand has increased the supply has been
relatively stagnant as far as medical
story is much better for women it's it's
much stronger and and we can delve and
I'm not going to delve at this point
into why this is the case a lot of it
has to do with K to 12 experience and
preschool preparation but the point is
many Americans are being left behind in
perception if not in fact and this has
been increasing polarization increasing
difficulties at the political level now
the ideal thing would be to fix the
problem directly fix education but if
education is difficult to tackle what do
you do well if you're a politician one
of the things you can do if you're
worried about this constituency is
redistribution but there has been
limited support for distribution
redistribution and there are huge costs
of doing it in terms of incentives and
so on well you think about what people
want people want consumption they don't
care as much about incomes if they have
consumption and so one way to create
that consumption is through credit
growth in fact whether by design by or
by happenstance what has happened is
housing has been the source of the
credit which has kept consumption
relatively strong especially for the
poorest households even at the expense
of increasing their debt levels
substantially moreover housing has the
additional benefit of giving houses that
are falling behind a stake in the future
if you say your savings are not growing
your income is not growing but your
house price is growing well that's an
asset that you have you feel more
comfortable and so in in many ways I
argue that homeownership was pushed as
the answer to a number of problems
stemming from rising in a income
inequality and income not not push not
growing it was it was a bipartisan
effort the affordable housing pushed by
Clinton which result
in Congress setting norms for Fannie and
Freddie to lend to lower-income segments
or the ownership society push by Bush
which resulted in some of those mandated
requirements for lending by Fannie and
Freddie to actually be increased during
George Aubrey Bush's time
why did the u.s. go further than this
than other countries well the US had the
instruments that could be put to work
somewhat paradoxically these were the
instruments that the u.s. used to bring
the United States out of the mess that
was created during the Depression these
were instruments like the Federal
Housing Authority like Fannie Mae which
was created around the time of the
depression and Freddie Mac which was
created more recently these were the
instruments the u.s. used to push
housing at low income segments in many
ways this was a classic emerging market
response to inequality a populist move
typically in emerging markets households
can't borrow so it's the government that
borrows and has populist programs in the
US the private sector was the
intermediary through government
organizations like Fannie Freddie the
FHA and the Community Reinvestment Act
so the point I'm trying to argue is why
was the u.s. in the forefront of pushing
consumption in part it was the political
forces within the US which is rising
levels of inequality strong political
pressure to do something the way to do
something that would have been right was
improve education hard to deal with
education the short-run very difficult
to change it easier waitress is to
expand credit populist credit expansions
time and again are the way that emerging
markets have dealt with the problem this
is where the u.s. became an emerging
market it pushed credit expansion as the
solution in addition though this was
just part of what was going on in
addition there was substantial stimulus
which led to the problem in the nineteen
in 2001 and and why was there such
enormous stimulus in the United States
and I will argue that in addition to the
underlying inequality which
problems the u.s. also has its low
threshold for pain in downturns and
that's because of the nature of the u.s.
system and what's been happening in the
u.s. system over the last few recoveries
is that the pain has increased let me
explain
u.s. recoveries used to be very fast you
go down and you come back very quickly
typically it took two quarters for
growth to recover from the trough of the
recession it took eight months to
recover all the lost jobs so in post-war
recessions and recoveries the u.s. went
down came back up
so in these circumstances you didn't
need a very strong safety net six months
insurance which is norm in the United
States was enough people lost their jobs
they got unemployment insurance but they
had a very strong incentive to look for
jobs because jobs will be coming back
and they actually got those jobs what's
been happening since 1991 is the pattern
of recoveries has changed in 1991 it
took three quarters for output to come
back it took twenty three months that is
almost eight quarters two years for jobs
to come back way beyond the time that
unemployment insurance runs out in 2001
took one-quarter for output come back it
was a de it was a sharp v-shaped
recovery in terms of output but it took
38 months that is close to three years
three and a half years for jobs to come
back so in that kind of environment when
it takes really long for jobs to come
back where our unemployment is really
long-term the pressure on the
politicians to actually stimulate the
economy till the jobs come back is
enormous so in 2001 you had a fiscal
stimulus which was large but you also
had a monetary stimulus I want to focus
on this people say the Fed was on hold
for too long well too long relative to
what they look at output growth and they
said well output growth came back the
Fed should have been
interest rates pretty quickly after
output growth start coming back but that
was not what was driving Fed policy what
the Fed was looking at was the
unemployment rate and the unemployment
rate was not budging it took much longer
for unemployment to start falling and
jobs to come back and so the Fed was on
hold for a relatively long time so point
I'm trying to make here is because of
the thin nature of the safety net and
because recoveries have certainly become
much more long drawn out in terms of job
recovery the pressure to stimulate till
the jobs come home is enormous which
typically means Fed policy is on hold
and to the extent that Fed policy keeps
interest rates at a very low level for a
long time it creates a whole set of
incentives in the private financial
sector which I'll come to in a second
but the last aspect I want to add here
is that it was not just low interest
rates at that point in order to push job
creation the Fed also made commitments
about being willing to infuse the
economy with liquidity if the economy
got into trouble this was a famous
Greenspan put and he said look we're
trying to help the economy the economy
gets into trouble we'll try and infuse
enough liquidity so as to make sure the
economy comes out of it again if there
was ever an excuse the financial sector
needed to go haywire to just go stretch
out on a limb and take risks
the Greenspan put was certainly one part
of it so what I want to argue then here
is that what we have is jobless
recoveries in the US overlaid on the
inequality and both these tend to
combine to create one directed credit
into housing to very stimulative
policies both of which tend to have an
effect on the financial sector so let me
come to the last part of what I want to
argue about what does all this have to
do with the crisis well we had a whole
lot of low quality mortgage-backed
securities created right why would this
creator
what role did the government play well
clearly the enormous amount of money
flooding into this sector from
government sources from foreign sources
money that didn't ask same kinds of
questions that the private sector would
have asked did play a role in making it
easier to sell these kinds of securities
and a lot of them were in fact sold so I
want to argue that's part of what was
what happened but the the critical
question we need to ask is why banks
held on to much of this risk and I want
to argue banks held on to much of this
risk because again the kinds of messages
that was being sent out by the monetary
and fiscal authorities was if you get
into trouble we will come to help you
and in fact that's what we've seen
happen and so the private financial
sector was in many ways incentivized to
do the kinds of things they did not
blameless they bear a big part of the
responsibility but it was part of the
incentive structure and let me end by
making those two points one why
mortgage-backed securities well a wall
of money was pouring to subprime lending
this gentleman Peter Wallison at the
American Enterprise Institute who's made
a study of this and has actually tapped
into sources from somebody who was at at
at Fannie and described the extent of
lending that went on from these
organizations into the subprime market
now this is a market that was really
non-existent in many ways it was quite
tiny
until the huge amount of money started
pouring into this market well when you
have a whole lot of money pouring in it
tends to distort prices it tends to
distort behavior also why the rating
agencies go berserk because there's a
tremendous appetite for the kinds of
securities that were being issued by the
rate they were being rated by the rating
agencies tremendous appetite which
certainly in the short run made it
convenient for them to forget about the
details of rating carefully and made
them a little more hospitable to what
the issuer wanted now were they doing
the right thing of course not
but they were incentivized in part by
the
all of money that that came in part of
the wall of money came in from
government mandates part of it came in
from foreign money which was looking for
higher-yielding safe securities together
I think they helped reduce the checks
and balances that were there on quality
and one story I like I like to tell is
that when banks held on to the stuff
when banks held on to low-quality
mortgages on the ban sheet they did a
really good job on doing due diligence
and trying to find out the quality of
the bar this is why banks didn't go
haywire in the early 1990s or the mid
1990s but as it became possible to sell
the stuff on towards less discriminating
foreign investors to Fannie and Freddie
who had a mandate to lend to this to
these kinds of sectors the kinds of
checks and balances that the banks
followed became weaker and weaker in
fact as they knew they could secure ties
and as a new the person on the other
side buying these securities had only
limited ways of checking what was in
them they focused more on the stuff that
they could check for example investors
in these mortgage-backed securities
could check the rating the credit rating
of the homeowners who held the
underlying mortgage so over time what
the bank's decided was I need a good
householder with an adequate credit
rating I don't care what else happens
all I want is a credit rating to be
right well once the mortgage broker
knows that all the bank is interested is
the credit rating of the homeowner he
works to massage the credit rating such
that that credit rating meets the bank's
norms and there was a lot of this
massaging going on so even while the
credit ratings of the house'll
homeowners who had borrowed remained
relatively high over time the underlying
quality was deteriorating why did all
this happen because at the end of the
line there is somebody willing to buy
the stuff without asking too many
questions there's a huge wall of money
pouring in and so to some extent the
wall of money does play a role in in in
determining
actually happen but you know the banks
who were issuing this stuff ended up
holding a whole lot of stuff on their
balance sheet while the banks hold this
stuff here didn't they know what was in
it and we have to we have to recognize
that you know it wasn't clear throughout
this process that we would have a crisis
of the order that we had what happened
was the incentives to maintain risk
controls to manage the risk were
weakened by the process that were going
on banks in many ways were taking a bet
and the bet that they were taking given
the nature of the financial system is
the best way to explain that is by
talking about earthquake insurance right
now in the financial sector in the
modern financial sector when you write
risks when you take on risks investors
are looking to see whether you make a
return over and above the risk that
you're taking on okay
in finance this is known as creating
alpha put differently if you hire a
money manager to manage them manage
money for the for you if all they do is
invest in S&P 500 securities it is clear
that that process of investing is
extremely easy it is a process that you
yourself can follow without hiring a
money manager why would you hire a money
manager to go out and invest in S&P 500
securities they could do you could do it
on your own what you're paying for is
they invest in large companies and do it
in such a clever way that they produce
additional returns
well managers find it very hard to
produce additional returns because it's
just very hard to beat the market well
one way you can beat the market is by
disguising the risk that you're taking
and this is where the analogy of
earthquake insurance comes in if I am
writing earthquake insurance but I don't
tell you I'm writing earthquake
insurance and I collect the premier from
all my customers who are paying me to
write earthquake insurance for them I'm
making a lot of money a lot of the time
I look like a genius because I'm showing
no risk
but of course when the earthquake hits
right I have to make a lot of pay up but
if by that time I've taken all this
money that I've made paid myself huge
bonuses paid my shareholders dividends
all I have the shell of a company right
better still if that shell of the
company is bailed out by the government
because then the taxpayer bears the cost
of all the wonderful things I've done
well in many ways this is what the
financial sector was doing it was trying
to portray that it was creating risk
adjusted returns but actually it was
writing various pawns of earthquake
insurance risks there would be extremely
costly when they hit but had relatively
low probability and while the going was
good they took the premium and peeled
out themselves paid out as dividends and
in some ways the government helped them
do it how did it help them do it well
you know when the government says if
there's a liquidity problem I am gonna
help you out I'm going to come and flood
the market with the QWERTY then I have
an incentive to take the kinds of
investments which will suffer when
there's a collapse of liquidity because
at that point I know the government is
going to come in even better if
everybody's doing it because I know for
certain the government is going to come
in and and support the markets so at one
level what the banks were doing was
essentially rolling the dice taking big
liquidity players investing in
mortgage-backed securities which ninety
five ninety nine percent of the time
would work out well but with small
probability would be a disaster right
and they were financing it with huge
loads of debt again you could easily
roll over the debt most of the time when
times are good with small probability
financing would drive amp but you know
under those circumstances you would
toast now why do I care about those
circumstances when I'm toast especially
the government is going to bail me out
I'm going to take this risk I'm going to
take these risks in spades and there is
evidence that this is what was happening
when you look at the companies that the
the most risks these were the companies
that were rewarded with the highest
stock prices in the 1990s they were the
ones with had the highest stock returns
they were the ones that before the
crisis in 2006 had the highest stock
prices the market was rewarding this
kind of behavior because they knew that
on the upside the shareholders and
investors benefited on the downside the
gut the government took the hint and
exposed what we've seen is exactly this
happened right yes there were a few
unfortunate institutions Lehman went
down you know Bear Stearns barely got
anything but if you look at the crisis
being a small probability event it made
sense for all these entities to go out
on the limb and take these risks because
when push came to shove the government
came in bailed out the banks with direct
intervention bailed out through
liquidity and is actively intervening in
the housing market the entire housing
market currently is being supported by
various government programs right so the
bottom line in this that I'm coming to
is essentially macro forces create a set
of circumstances where the government
pushes housing wants to push activity
creates support systems which encourage
the financial sector to take certain
kinds of risks eventually when the risks
say emerge the government comes in and
bails out the financial sector right and
the problem is now that we've done it
once in a big way what's to prevent us
from doing it again what's to prevent
the financial sector from taking these
kinds of risks knowing that the
government cannot in fact resist coming
in to support the system especially if
the political environment in the United
States gets more and more gets weaker
and weaker over time so basically how do
we prevent it from happening again
and my sense is
you have to have financial sector
reforms but also I think you have to
have real sector reforms so that the
government in a sense is not taken
advantage of by the financial sector the
government can actually do the things it
needs to do for example education reform
for example we have to debate whether
safety net has to be made stronger given
the fact that recoveries are much more
drawn-out we have to understand why they
more drown out and there's some theories
on that but if they are here to stay
does the United States require a
stronger safety net so that the brunt is
taken by the safety net rather than by
policies that are in in some ways
encouraging the kind of risk-taking that
actually took place should it be the
safety net rather than monetary policy
that tries to bring some that that puts
some kind of floor on what happens in in
recession so let me given that we are
running out of time let me end with this
last point clearly in the financial
sector we need reforms the reforms to my
mind has have to focus not on equity not
on it has a focus on making sure that
investors absorb the downside risks that
they are creating that they're allowing
the banks to create and more than
anything else this means that debt
holders when there's a calamity of the
kind that we've seen bare some of the
costs of that calamity bear some of the
cost of the downside bear the hid and
therefore focusing on them absorbing the
head there has to be central to our
policies trying to get equity people say
it was a lack of governance what I'm
trying to argue that if you were
governing the bank in the interests of
your shareholders you would take these
beds because most of the time you would
take a much you make a ton of money in
fact that's what the stall Act while the
city banks of the world who took all
this risk their stock price zoomed the
market was cheering you on because these
kinds of risks made sense for the
shareholder so you can't rely on the
shareholder to control management to
keep these risks under control you have
to rely on the downside one important
source of downside would be if it hit
the debt holders
they would keep the bank from getting
too big for the US we need you the US to
have more effective policies especially
for downturns
I think structurally there is an issue
about the growing inequality and can we
resolve the growing inequality by
improving access to education for
example rather than focusing on
redistribution there's that debate is
alive in the u.s. today if we go down
the part of redistribution to my mind
that will remove some of the Flair and
innovation that exists in the US economy
we need to go down the path of improving
access to making sure more of the
citizenry get access to good sound
education how do we do that
how do we keep little people happy while
that's happening that's I think the
central question the United States has
to it has to face but I think the health
care debate sort of feeds into that
second as far as downturns go how do we
preserve the flexibility and the
innovation that is in the US economy as
a result of being able to hire and fire
relatively quickly even while
recognizing the nature of the recession
has changed and maybe the safety net
needs to be a stronger and more long-run
on safety net this to my mind are the
central political questions the u.s. has
to answer and we will answer them in
some fashion over the next few years but
if we don't answer them and we leave
these questions on tackled u.s. policy
is going to be relatively inadequate for
the needs of the moment and in u.s.
policy of course is a reaction to
another factor which is outside the US
is control which is the behavior of
countries outside the US the surplus
countries Japan Germany now China
increasingly joining that how do you
deal with these surplus countries and
get them to see that more bands growth
is in the world's interest that the u.s.
cannot continue to be the consumer of
last resort they cannot continue to rely
on bad US policy which results in the
kinds of downturns that we've seen the
kind of crisis that we've seen to hold
their growth up how do we get them to
play a bigger part in contributing to
world growth that to my mind is the
central question
facing global governance it's a question
that there are no easy answers to and
let me end at that point